I'm gonna build the smokehouse so
starting there I'm gonna have to go find
some nice post and get the bark peeled
off of them and some poles start getting
all my material so I'm gonna head
downriver and look for a really good
spot to cut post and poles at that's a
nice looking spot here maybe all right
let's load out to West come on West
oh good boy the beavers have really been
at work here you know and you can tell
there's some nice old season wood is
exactly what I'm looking for for smoking
my fish looks like some good wood in
here no I'm looking for something not
too big that's not gonna kill me to
carry to the boat
I'm a very social person but when I'm
working feel like I do my best work
along way I can just enjoy my time this
is the spot where I'm gonna build my
fish camp and uh it's kind of an ideal
location for me because my house it's
only about five miles from here
work on taking the bark off of these so
they can sit out here and bake and kind
of dry and not be so slippery I got a
log spud but I used hopefully these
aren't to dry it on what you can do is
you get a strip started going off of
these feeling pretty good hums all right
now I have all my material here clear
out some brush to open this up so I
won't be tripping and falling over it
right here's where I'm gonna put my
smokehouse so I need to clear this brush
out of here
you
I'm last post yeah so now I'm on in my
next days and now I'm just gonna start
tying it all together with the flanking
the flanking for the sides of my
smokehouse it'll nail unto my post come
from a sawmill my friends own its
bartered for with him
got enough of these on to get some
structure to where I can get up higher
now and get my ladder on it and then I'm
gonna run my cross pieces across which
I'll put my roofing poles on
like that
I'm gonna put a tarp on the top for a
roof it'll shed water nice with this
nice slope then I'm gonna be able to go
get my dogs and finish setting up camp
and get some rest